der fall eileen er ist endlich gelöst
denn die der tatverdächtige hat den
grausamen mord an der erst 14 jährigen
aus baden württemberg gestanden wir
wollen uns den fall noch mal anschauen
am 21 juli verlässt aline gegen 18 uhr
ihr elternhaus die 14 jährige wollte
einem freund in der nachbarschaft ein
pullover bringen doch die schülerinnen
kehrte nicht mehr nach hause zurück acht
tage später dann gab die polizei bekannt
dass eine mädchenleiche im teufelssee in
hessen gefunden wurde und dann die
traurige gewissheit aline ist tot und
das hier ist der killer jan hajek op ist
bereits polizeibekannt und vorbestraft
der richter hat haftbefehl gegen ihn
erlassen er sitzt jetzt wegen des
verdachts eines vorsätzlichen
tötungsdelikts in u-haft die beamten
hatten zuvor handy und funkzellen daten
ausgewertet und als kleidung in seiner
wohnung gefunden er hatte das mädchen im
internet beim spiel fortnight
kennengelernt und jetzt also ist auch
dieser fall glücklicherweise geklärt